The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CARLO CILIBERTO: Good morning.
So today, there is
a bit if a overview
on the iCub Robot, and it
will be about one hour, one
hour and half.
And we organized the
schedule for this time
in series of four small
talks and then a demo
from the iCub, live demo.
So I will give you an
overview of the kind of fields
and capabilities that the
iCub has developed so far,
while Alessandro, Rafaello,
and Giulia will show you
what's going on right
now on the iCub, part
of what's going on the robot.
So they are going to talk
about their recent work.
So let's start with
the presentation.
This is the iCub, which
is a child humanoid robot.
This size.
And the project of the iCub
began in 2004, and the iCub--
actually, the iCubs, because
there are many of them--
they were built in Genoa
at the Italian Institute
of Technology.
And the main motivation behind
the creation and the design
of this platform was
to actually have a way
to have a platform in order
to study how intelligence,
how cognition emerges in
artificial embodied systems.
So Giulio Sandini and Giorgio
Metta, that you can see there,
are the actual original
founders of iCub world,
so they are both
directors at the IIT.
And this is a bit of a
timeline that I drew.
Actually, there are many
other things going on
during all these 11 years.
This is a video celebrating
the actual first 10 years
of the project.
And actually, you can
see many more things
that the iCub will
be able to do.
But I selected
this part because I
think they can be useful, also,
if you are interested in doing
projects with the robot, to have
an idea of the kind of skills
and the kind of feedback that
the robot can provide you,
to do an experiment.
So as I told you, iCub
was built with the idea
of replicating an artificial
embodied system that
could explore the environment
and learn from it.
So it has many
different sensors.
These are some of them.
So in the head, we have one
accelerometer and the gyroscope
in order to provide the
inertial feedback to the system,
and two Dragonfly cameras
that provide medium resolution
images.
And as you can see
there, it's all
about one meter, one
meter and something,
and it's pretty light--
55 kilograms-- and has a
lot of degrees of freedom.
So 53 degrees of
freedom, and they
allow the robot to perform
many complicated actions.
It's provided with
torque and force sensors,
and I will go over
these in a minute.
Its whole body, or at least
the covered part of the robot--
the black part that
you can see there--
are all covered in
artificial skin.
So they provide
feedback about contact
with the external world.
And it has also microphones
mounted on the head,
but probably for sound
and speech recognition
is better to use direct
microfeedback at the moment,
because, of course,
noise-canceling problems
and so on.
If you're interested in
speech and found feedback,
we are going to use
other kind of microphone.
So during these
11 years, iCub has
been involved in
many, many projects,
and indeed, part of what
I'm going to show you
is the result of the joint
effort of many labs, mainly
in Europe.
These are mostly
European projects.
But iCub is also an
international partner
of the CBMM Project.
So regarding
force/torque sensors,
they are these sensors
that you can see there.
So they provide [INAUDIBLE]
and also [INAUDIBLE]..
And they're mounted
in each of the limbs
of the robot and the torso.
And they allow the robot
to [INAUDIBLE] interaction
with the world.
And indeed, with
this kind of object,
it can do many different things.
For instance in this video,
I'm showing an example
of how the feedback provided
by the force/torque sensor
can be used to guide the
robot and teach it to learn
different kind of action.
Like, in this case, a
pouring action and then
repeat it and maybe
try to generalize it.
So force/torque sensors
provide the robot feedback
about the intensity
of the interaction
with the external world.
But they're not allowed
to have the robot have
an idea of where this kind
of interaction is occurring.
So, for this, we have artificial
skin covering the robot,
as I told you.
And the technology used
for the kind of thing,
that you can see here, for the
palm of the hand of the robot,
is capacitive and it's
similar to the technology used
for smart phones.
It's using, if you can
see these yellow dots.
They are all electrodes that,
together with another arm,
they form a capacitor.
The way the arm works
of this capacitor
are formed when there
is an interaction
with the environment
allowed to provide
the feedback of the kind
of intensity [INAUDIBLE]
the location itself.
It's providing
information about where
this interaction is occurring.
And the artifical
skin is actually
really useful for
an embodied agent.
And for reasons like
we see in this video,
without using this feedback, if
you have a very light object,
the robot is not able to detect
the process is interrupting
with something.
It's just closing the end and
it doesn't have any feedback.
It's crushing the object.
By using the sensors on
the fingertips of the hand,
the robot is able to
detect that it's actually
touching something,
and therefore, it's
stopping the action without
crushing the object.
So other useful things that can
be done with artificial skin.
This is an example of
combining the information
from the force/torque sensor
and the artificial skin.
So the artificial skin
allows to detect where
and the direction
of the kind of force
that is applied to the robot.
And in that case, the
robot is counterbalancing.
It's negating the effect of
gravity and of internal forces.
So it's basically having
arm floating around like
if it was in space.
And there is no friction.
So by touching the
arm of the robot,
we have the arm drifting
in the direction opposite
to where the force is
applied, or the torque.
You can see that,
the arm is turning.
But as you can see, like it was
in space without any friction,
because it's actually
negating both gravity
and internal forces.
And finally, again about
the artificial skin,
there's some work by
Alessandro, but he's
going to talk about
something else,
but I found is particularly
interesting to show him.
This is an example of the
robot self-calibrating
the model of its own body,
with respect to its own hand.
The idea is to have the robot
use the tactile feedback
from the fingertip and the skin
of its forearm, for instance,
to learn the position between
the fingertip and the arm.
And therefore, it's able,
first by touching itself,
to learn the
correspondence and then
to actually show
that it has learned
this kind of correlation by
reaching the point when someone
else touches the thing point.
And tries to reach it.
And therefore, this can be seen
as a way of self-calibrating
without the need of a model of
the kinematics of the robot.
The robot would just be able
to explore itself and learn
how different part of it's
body relate one to the other.
And again, related to
self-calibration sometimes,
but this is more of a
calibration between vision
and motor activity.
This is a work appeared in
2014 in which, basically,
the correlation between the kind
of actions that the robot is
able to perform is calibrated
with respect to its ability
to perceive the work.
So, in this kind of
video I'm going to show,
the robot is trying
to reach for an object
and failing in its action
because the actual model
of the word that you use
to perform the reaching
is not aligned with the 3-D
model provided by vision.
And this can happen
due to smaller errors
in the kinematics
or in the vision
and therefore even
just small errors
cause a complete
failure of the system.
And therefore, by trying to
correlate that information,
the one from the kinematics,
in this case the robot
is using it on the fingertip
to the see where it actually
is in the image.
And when the kinematic model
predicts the hand should be.
So the green dot is the point,
predicted by kinematics,
of where the system expects
the fingertip to be,
and where actually
the fingertip is.
Of course, by learning
this relation,
the robot is able to cope with
this kind of misalignment.
And therefore, after a
first calibration phase,
it's able to perform the
reaching action, successfully,
as you will see in a moment.
Also, this kind of
ability of calibrating
would be pretty useful in case
of the situations in which
the robot is damaged, and
therefore, it's actual model
changes completely.
As you can see,
now it's reaching
and it's performing
the grasp correctly.
Finally, before going
with the actual talk,
I'm going to show a final
video about balancing.
Some of you have asked
if the robot works,
and the robot is currently
not able to work,
but this is a video
from the people
from the group that
is actually in charge
of making the robot work.
The first step, of
course, will be balancing.
And this is an example of it.
It's actually one
foot balancing where
multiple components of what
I've shown you about the iCub
so far.
Torque sensing, initial
sensing are combined together
to have the robot
stand on one foot.
And also be able to cope
with the interaction
with internal forces that
could try to have it fall.
They are applying
forces to the robot
and it's able to
detect the force
and to cope a bit with the
forces but to stay stable.
OK so, this was just
a brief overview
of some things that can
be done with the iCub.
And actually, the next
talk will be a bit more
about what's going on with it.
ALESSANDRO RONCONE: I want
to talk to you about part
of my PhD project that was
about tackling the perception
problem.
Tackling the perception
problem through the use
of multisensor integration.
And specifically, I narrowed
down this big problem
by implementing a model of
PeriPersonal Space on the iCub.
That is, biology
inspired approach.
PeriPersonal Space
is a concept that
has been known in neuroscience
and psychology for years.
And so, let me start with
what PeriPersonal Space is,
and why it is so important
for humans and animals.
It is defined as
the space around us,
within which objects can
be grasped and manipulated.
It's an interface,
basically, between our body
and the external world.
And for this reason,
it benefits from
a multimodal integrated
representation
that merges information
between different modalities.
And historically, these
have been the vision system,
the tactile system, the
perception, auditory system,
and even the motor system.
Historically, it
has been studied
by two different fields.
The neurophysiology on
one side, and all that
could be related to psychology
and developmental psychology
on the other.
They basically follow the
two different approaches,
the former being bottom up,
the latter being top down.
And they came out with
different outcomes.
And the former emphasizes
the role of the perception
and it interplays
with the motor system
in the control of movement,
whereas the latter was focusing
mainly on the
multisensory aspect, that
is, how different modalities
were combined together
in order to form a
coherent view of the body
and the nearby space.
Luckily, in recent
years, they decided
to converge to a common ground,
and a shared interpretation,
and for the purposes
of my work I
would like to highlight
the main aspect.
Firstly, and this one might be
of interest from an engineering
perspective.
PeriPersonal Space is made
of different reference
points that are located in
different regions of the brain.
And there might be
a way for the brain
to switch from one to another,
according to different contact
and goal.
And secondly, as I was
saying, PeriPersonal Space
benefits from a
multisensory integration
in order to form a coherent
view of the body understanding
space.
In this experiment made
by Fogassi in 1996,
they basically found a number
of so-called visual tactile
neurons that are set up neurons
that fire both stimulated
in a specific skin part
and if an object is
presented in surrounding space.
So this means that
these neurons code
both the visual information
and the tactile information.
But they also have some
proprioceptive information,
because they are basically
attached to the body part
that they belong to.
Lastly, one of the main
properties of this presentation
is in basic plasticity.
And for example,
in this experiment,
made by Iriki ten years ago,
the extension of this receptive
field in the visual space,
in the surrounding space,
after training with
a rake, have been
shown to go up to
enclose the tool
as if this tool becomes
part of the body.
So through experience
and through tool use,
the monkey was able to
grow this receptive field.
Those are properties
that are very nice,
and we would like them to
be available for the robot.
And, in general
robotics, the work
related to PeriPersonal Space
can be divided into two groups.
On the one side, the model,
and the simulation basically.
The closest one to
my work was the one
from Fuke, a colleague that
are from [INAUDIBLE] lab,
in which they used a
stimulated robot in order
to model the mechanisms
that are leading
to this visual-tactile
presentation.
On the other side, there are
the engineering approaches
that are few.
The closest one is this
one by Mittendorfer
from Gordon Cheng's
lab, in which they first
developed the multimodal skin.
So they developed the hardware
to be able to do that.
And then they use the to trigger
local avoidance responses,
reflexes to incoming objects.
We are trying to position
ourself in the middle.
Let's say, we are
not trying to create
a perfect model of
PeriPersonal Space
from a biological perspective.
But on the other
side, we would like
to have something that is
also working, and useful
for our proposals.
So from now on, I will divide
the presentation in two parts.
The first will be
about the model.
So what we think will be useful
for tackling the problem,
on the other side I show you an
application of this model, that
is basically using the
low-color presentation in order
to trigger avoidance responses
or reaching responses
distributed throughout the body.
So let me start
with the proposed
model of PeriPersonal Space.
Loosely inspired by the
neurophysiological findings
like we discussed before, we
developed this PeriPersonal
Space presentation
by means of access
of facial receptive field
that we are going out
from the robot's skin.
So basically, they were
extending the tactile domain
into nearby space.
Each tactile, that is, each pair
the iCub skin is composed of,
will experience a set
of multisensory events.
So basically, you
are letting the robot
learn this visual-tactile
sensations by taking an object
and making contact
on the skin part.
We learn it by
tactile experience
we learn a sort of probability
of being touched prior
to contact activation when
the new incoming object is
presented.
And we basically created this
cone shape receptive field
that is going from
each of the taxels.
And for any object that is
entering this receptive field,
we created we called a buffer,
of the path so basically,
the idea is that the orbit
has some information from what
was going on before they
touch, the actual contact.
And if the object eventually
ends up touching the tactile,
it will be labeled as
a positive event that
will enforce the
probability of the event
the ending of
touching the taxel.
If not, for example, it might
be that the object enters
this receptive field,
and in the end,
ends up touching another taxel.
This will be labeled
as a negative.
So at the end, we will have a
set of positive and negative
events a taxel can learn from.
This is three dimensional
space because the distance
is three dimensional.
And we narrowed it down to
a one dimensional domain,
by basically, taking the
norm of the distance,
but also the relative position
of the object and the taxel.
In order for us to be able
to cope with the calibration
errors that were amounting
up to a couple of centimeters
that were significant.
One dimensional
variable has been
discretized into a set of bins.
And for each bin, we
computed the probability
of an event belonging to
that, of being touched.
So the idea is that,
at 20 centimeters,
the probability of being
touched would be lower
than a zero centimeter.
This is the intuitive idea.
Over this one dimensional
visualization,
we used a partial window
interpolation technique
in order to provide us with
the two dimensional function
that, at the end, we
give up a inactivation
value that is proportional with
the distance of the object.
So as soon as the new object
will enter the receptive field,
I will have the taxel fire
before being contacted.
We did, basically,
two experiments.
Initially, we did a simulation
in a mock lab in order
to assess the convergence
on the long term
learning, one-shot
learning behavior,
to assess if our model was
able to cope with noise,
with the current
calibration errors.
And then, we went
on the real robot.
We presented them with
different objects.
And we were basically
touching the robot 100 times
in order to make it learn
these presentations.
So, trust me, I don't
want to bother you
with this kind of
technicalities,
but we did a lot of work.
This is, basically,
the math of the result.
So, let me go on the second
part, in which the main problem
was for the robot to
detect the object visually.
In order for us to do that,
we developed a 3D tracking
algorithm, that was able to
track a [INAUDIBLE] object,
basically.
To design, we used
some software that
was only available in the
iCub software repository.
The engine provides you
with some basic algorithms
that you can play with.
And namely, we used a two
dimensional optical flow
made by Carlo and a
2D particle filter
and a 3D stereo
vision algorithm,
that is basically the same
as I was showing before
during the recognition game.
And this basically was
feeding a 3-D camera
to provide the robot estimation
of the position of the object.
So, the idea is that the motion
detector from the optical flow
act as a trigger for the
subsequent pipeline, in which,
basically, after a
consistent enough motion
in this optical flow module,
this would be a template
to be taught in the visual in
the 2D visual world by this.
Then, that this information
is sent to the 3D depth map
and this would be feeding
the camera feature in order
to provide us with the table
representation because,
obviously, the stereo system
doesn't work that good
in our context.
And this, if it works--
no.
OK.
On my laptop, it works here.
Now it works.
OK.
This is the idea.
So I was basically
waving, moving
the object in the beginning.
OK.
Then when it is detected,
this pattern starts.
And you can see
here the tracking.
This is the stereo vision.
This the final outcome.
This was used for the learning.
We did a lot of iterations
of these objects
that are approaching the
skin on different body parts.
This is the graph.
I don't want to talk about that.
So let me start with the video.
This is basically the skin.
And this is the part that
it was trained before.
When there is a contact,
there is activation here.
You can see here the activation.
And soon after, this thing
worked also with one example.
The taxel starts firing
before the contact.
And obviously, this is
improved over the time.
And it depends on the
body part that is touched.
For example, if I touch here,
I'm coming from the top.
So the representation
starts firing mainly here.
And this, obviously, depends
on the specific body part.
Now, I think that I'm
going to touch the hand.
And so after a while, you will
have an activation on the hand.
Obviously, I will have also
some activation in the forearm,
because I was getting
closer to the forearm.
And as an application
of this, this one
is simply a presentation.
So it's not that usable.
We basically exploited it in
order to develop an avoidance--
a margin of safety
around the body.
Let's say if the
taxel is firing,
I would like it to go
away from the object,
assuming that this can be a
potentially harmful object.
And on the other
way, I would like
it to be able to reach
with any body part
the object under consideration.
So to this end, we developed
the avoidance and catching
controller that was able to
leverage on this distributed
information and perform
a sensor-based guidance
of the model actions by
means of this visual tactile
associations.
And this is basically
how it works.
So this is at the testing stage.
So I already learned
the representation.
As soon as I get
closer, the taxel
starts firing, because of the
probabilities I was learning.
And the arm goes away.
Obviously, the movement
depends on the specific skin
part that has been touched.
If I'm touching here, the
object will go away from here.
If I'm coming from the top--
I think this one was
doing from the top, yes--
the object will go
away from the back.
The object will be going a
way from another direction.
And the idea here is not to,
basically, tackle the problem
from a classical
robotics approach.
But the basic
idea-- this behavior
emerges from the learning.
And the idea was very simple.
We were basically looking at
the taxel that we were firing.
If they were firing
enough, then we
were recording their position.
And we were doing,
basically, a population
coding that is a weighted
average according
to the activation
and the prediction.
We did that to both
for the position
of the taxel and the normal.
So at the end if you have
a bunch of tactiles here,
we will end up with one
point to go away from.
And on the other side, the
catching, the reaching,
was basically the same, but
in the opposite direction.
So if I want to
avoid, I do this.
If I want to catch, I do this.
Obviously, if you
do it in the hand,
this would be a standard
robotic reaching.
But this actually
can be triggered also
in different body parts.
As you can see here, I get a
virtual activation, and then
the physical contact.
And yes, basically, our design
was to use the same controller
for both of the behaviors.
OK.
This is also some technicalities
that I don't want to show you.
So in conclusion, the
detector presented here
is, to our knowledge,
the first attempt
at creating a decentralized,
multisensory visual tactile
representation for a
robot and its nearby space
by means of the distributed
skin and interaction
with the environment.
One of the assets of
our representation
is that learning is fast.
As you were seeing,
it can learn, also,
from one single example.
It's in parallel for the
whole body in the sense
that every tactile
learns independently.
Its own representation
is incremental in a sense
that it converges toward
a stable representation
over the time.
And importantly, it is
adapted from experience.
So basically, it
can automatically
compensate for errors
in the model that,
for humanoid robots, is
one of the main problems
when merging different
modalities OK.
Thank you.
If you have any question,
feel free to ask.
RAFFAELLO CAMORIANO:
I am Raffaello.
And today, I'll talk to
you about a little bit
of my work on machine
learning and robotics,
in particular some subsets
of machine learning
which are the large
scale learning
and incremental learning.
But what do we expect
from our modern robot?
And how can machine
learning help out with this?
Well, we expect
modern robots to work
in, particularly,
unstructured environments
which they have
never seen before
and to learn new
tasks on the fly
depending on the
particular needs
throughout the operation
of the robot itself
and across different modalities.
For instance--
vision, of course,
but also tactile sensing which
is available on the iCub also
proprioceptive
sensing, including
force sensing, [INAUDIBLE]
and so on and so forth.
And we want to do all of this
throughout a very long time
span potentially.
Because we expect
robots to be companions
of humans in the real
world operating for maybe
years or more.
And this poses a
lot of challenges,
especially from the
computational point of view.
And machine learning
can actually
help with this tackling
these challenges.
For instance, there
are large scale
learning methods, which are
algorithms which can work
with very large scale datasets.
For instance, if we have
millions of points gathered
by the robot cameras
throughout 10 days
and we want to
process them, well,
if we use standard
machine learning methods,
that will be a very
difficult problem
to solve if we don't use, for
instance, randomizing methods
and so on and so forth.
Machine learning also has
incremental algorithms,
which can allow the
learned model to be updated
as new previously unseen
features are presented
to the agent.
And also, there is a
subfield of transfer learning
which allows knowledge
learned for a particular task
to be used for serving another
related task without the need
for seeing many new
examples for the new task.
So my main research focuses
are in machine learning.
I work especially in large
scale learning methods,
incremental learning,
and in the design
of algorithms which allow for
computational and accuracy
trade-offs.
I will explain this
a bit more later.
And as concerns
robotic applications,
I work with Guilia,
Carlo and others
on incremental
object recognition,
so in a setting in which the
robot is presented new objects
throughout a long time span.
And it has to learn
them on the fly.
And also, I'm working in a
system identification setting,
which I will explain
later, related
to the motion of the robot.
So this is one of
the works which
has occupied my last year.
And it is related to
large scale learning.
So if we consider that we may
have a very large n, which
is a number of examples
we have access to,
in the setting of
kernel methods,
we may have to store a huge
matrix, the matrix K, which
is n by n, which could be
simply impossible to store.
So there are randomized methods,
like the Nystrom method, which
enable to compute a low rank
approximation of the kernel
metrics simply by throwing
a few points m at random,
a few samples at random, and
building the metrics K and m,
which is just much smaller.
Because m is much
smaller than n.
And this is a well-known
method in machine learning.
But we tried to see it from
a different point of view
than usual.
Usually, this is seen just from
a computational point of view
in order to fit a difficult
problem inside computers
with limited capabilities
while we proposed
to see the Nystrom
approximation as regularization
of operation itself.
So if you can see this, the
usual way in which the Nystrom
method is applied, for instance,
with kernel regularized least
squares.
The parameter m, so
the number of examples
we are taking at
random, is usually taken
as large as possible
in order just
to fit in the memory of
the available machines.
While, actually, after
choosing a large m,
it is often necessary
to regularize
with deep neural
regularization, for instance.
And this sounds a bit like
a waste of time and memory.
Because, actually, what
regularization, roughly
speaking, does is to discard
the irrelevant eigen components
of the kernel metrics.
So we observe that
we can do this
by just less random examples,
so having a smaller model which
can be computed more
efficiently and without having
to regularize again later.
So m, the number of
examples which are used,
controls both the
regularization and
the computational
complexity of our algorithm.
This is very useful in a
robotic setting in which we
have to deal with lots of data.
As regards to the incremental
objects recognition task,
this is another
project I'm working on.
And imagine that the
robot has to work
in an unknown environment, and
it is presented novel objects
on the fly.
And it has to update its
object recognition model
in an efficient way
without retraining
from scratch every time
a new object arrives.
So this can be done easily
by a slight modification
of the regularized
least squares algorithm
and proper reweighting.
An open question is how to
change the regularization
as n grows.
Because we didn't find
yet a way to efficiently
update regularization
parameter in this case.
So we are still working on this.
The last project I'll talk about
is more related to, let's see,
physics and motion.
So we have an arbitrary
limb of the robot,
for instance, the arm.
And our task is to learn
a model which can provide
an interesting dynamics model.
So it can predict the
inner forces of the arm
during motion.
This is useful, for instance,
in a contact detection setting.
So when the sensor readings
are different from the group
predicted one, that means
that there may be a contact.
Or for external force
estimation or, for example,
for the identification of the
mass of a manipulated object.
So we have some challenged
for this project.
We have to devise a model
which could be interpretable,
so in which the rigid body
dynamic parameter would
be understandable
and intelligible
for controlled purposes.
And we wanted this
model to be more
accurate than standard multibody
dynamics, rigid body dynamics
model.
And also, we want to adapt
to changing conditions
throughout time.
For instance, during the
operation of the robot,
after one hour, the
changes in temperature
determine a change also
in the dynamic properties
of the mechanical
properties of the arm.
And we want to accommodate for
this in an incremental way.
So this is what we did.
We implemented a
semi-parametric model
which the first part
which has priority
is a simple incremental
parametric model.
And then we used random
features for building
non-parametric incremental
model which can
be updated in an efficient way.
And we shown with
this real experiment
that the semi-parametric
model worked
as well as the
non-parametric one.
But it's faster to
converge, because it
has an initial knowledge
about the physics of the arm.
And it is also better than
the fully parametric one,
because it also
models, for example,
dynamical effect due to
deflectability of the body.
And dynamic deflectors
are usually not modeled
by rigid body dynamic models.
OK.
Another thing I'm doing is
maintaining the Grand Unified
Regularized Least
Squares library,
which is a library for
regularized least squares,
of course.
It supports a large
scale dataset.
This was developed in joint
exchange between MIT and IIT
some years ago by
others, not by me.
And it has a MATLAB
and a C++ interface.
If you want to have a look
at how these methods work,
I suggest you to
try out tutorials
which are available on GitHub.
GUILIA PASQUALE: I'm Guilia.
And I work on the iCub
robot with my colleagues,
especially on vision
and, in particular,
on visual recognition.
I work under the supervision
of Lorenzo Natale and Lorenzo
Rosasco.
Both will be here for a few
days in the following weeks.
And the work that
I'm going to present
has been done in
collaboration with Carlo
and also Francesca Odone
from the University of Genoa.
So in the last couple of
years, computer vision methods
based on deep convolution
on neural networks
have achieved a
remarkable performance
in tasks such as
large scale image
classification and retrieval.
And the extreme success
of these methods
is mainly due to the
increasing availability
of all these larger datasets.
And in particular, I'm referring
to the ImageNet one, which
is composed by millions of
examples labeled into thousands
of categories through
crowd sourcing methods
such as the Amazon Turk.
And in particular, the
increased data availability
to gather with the increased
computational power
has allowed to train deep
networks characterized
by millions of parameters
in a supervised way
from the image up
to the final label
through the back
propagation algorithm.
And this has allowed to mark a
breakthrough-- in particular,
in 2012 when Alex
Krizhevsky proposed
for the first time of a
network of this kind trained
on ImageNet dataset
and definitely won
the ImageNet large
scale user recognition
challenge in this way.
And the trend has been confirmed
in the following years.
So that nowadays problems
such as large scale image
classification or
detection are usually
tackled following this
deep learning approach.
And not only, it has been
also demonstrated at least
empirically.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Maybe this is not
particularly clear.
But this is the
Krizhevsky Network.
Models of networks of this
kind trained on large datasets,
such as the ImageNet
one, do provide also
very good general
and powerful image
descriptors to be applied also
on other tasks and datasets.
In particular, it
is possible to use
a convolutional neural network
trained on ImageNet dataset,
feed it with
images, and using it
as a black box extracting
the vectorial representation
of the incoming images
as the output of one
of the intermediate layers.
Or even better, it is possible
to start from a network
model trained on
the ImageNet dataset
and fine tune its parameters
on a new dataset for a new task
and achieving and surpassing
the state of the art--
for example, also in the Pascal
dataset and other tasks--
following this approach.
So it is natural to
ask at this point, why?
Instead, in robotics,
providing robots
with robust and accurate
visual recognition capabilities
in the real world is still one
of the greatest challenge that
prevents the use of
autonomous agents
for concrete applications.
An actually, this is a problem
that is not only related
to the iCub platform, but
it is also a limiting factor
that the performance
of the latest
robotics platforms,
such as the ones that
have been participating, for
example, to the DARPA robotics
challenge.
Indeed, as you can
see here, robots
are still either highly
tele-operated or complex
methods.
To, for example, map the 3D
structure on the environment
and label it a priori must
be implemented in order
to enable autonomous
agents to act in very
controlled environments.
So we decided to focus
on very simple settings
where, in principle,
computer vision
methods as the ones that
I've been describing you
should be at least--
well, should provide
very good performances.
Because here the setting
is pretty simple.
And we tried to
evaluate the performance
of these deep learning
methods in these settings.
Here you can see
the robot, that one,
standing in front of a table.
There is a human which
gives verbal instruction
to the robot and also,
for example in this case,
the label of the object to be
either learned or recognized.
And the robot can focus his
attention on potential objects
through bottom up segmentation
techniques-- for example,
in this case, color or the other
saliency-based segmentation
methods.
I'm not going into the
detail of this setting,
because you would see a
demo after my talk of this.
Another setting that
we are considering
is similar to the previous one.
But this time, there is a human
standing in front of the robot.
And there is no table.
And the human, he's holding
the objects in his hands
and is showing one
object after the other
to the robot providing
the verbal annotation
for that object.
The robot in this
way, for example
here, can exploit motion
detection techniques
in order to localize the
object in the visual field
and focus on it.
The robot tracks the
object continuously,
acquiring in this way
cropped the frames
around the object that are
the training examples that
will be used to learn
the object's appearance.
So in general, this is
the recognition pipeline
that is implemented to
perform both the two behaviors
that I've been showing you.
As you can see, the
input is the image,
the stream of images from
one of the two cameras.
Then there is the verbal
supervision of the teacher.
Then there are
segmentation techniques
in order to crop
region of interest
from the incoming frame
and feed this crop
to a convolutional
neural network.
In this case, we are using
the famous Krizhevsky model.
Then we encode
each incoming crop
in a vector as the output
of one of the latest
layers of the network.
And we feed all these vectors
to a linear classifier,
which is linear because, in
principle, the representation
that we are extracting is good
enough for the discrimination
that we want to perform.
And so the classifier uses
these incoming vectors
either as examples for
the training sector
or assigns to each vector
the prediction label.
And the output is an histogram
with the probabilities
of all the classes.
And the final outcome is the one
with the highest probability.
And the histogram is
updated in real time.
So this pipeline
can be used either
for one or the other settings
that have been described you.
So in particular, we
started from trying
to list some requirements
that according to us
are fundamental in
order to implement
a sort of ideal robotic
visual recognition system.
And these requirements
are usually not considered
by typical computer vision
methods as the ones that
have been described you,
but are the same fundamental
if we want to
achieve human level
performances in the settings
that I've been showing you.
For example, first
of all, the system
should be, as you
have seen, as much
as possible self-supervised,
meaning that there must
be techniques in order
to focus that robot's
attention on the
object of interest
and isolate them from
the visual field.
Then hopefully, we
would like to come out
with a system that is
reliable and robust
to the variations
in the environment
and also in the
object's appearance.
Then also, as we are
in the real world,
we would like a
system able to exploit
the contextual information
that is available.
For example-- the fact
that we are actually
dealing with videos.
So the frames are
temporarily correlated.
And we are not dealing
with images in the wild,
as the ImageNet case.
And finally, as
Raffaello was mentioning,
we would like to
have a system that
is able to learn
incrementally to build always
richer models of the
object through time.
So we decided to evaluate
this recognition pipeline
according to the criteria
that have been described you.
And in order to provide
reproducibility to our study,
we decided to acquire
a dataset on which
to perform our analysis.
However, we would like
also to be confident enough
that the result that we
obtain on our benchmark
will hold also in the
real usage of our system.
And this is the
reason why we decided
to acquire our dataset in the
same application setting where
the robot usually operates.
So this is the
iCubWork28 dataset
that I acquired last year.
As you can see, it's
composed by 28 objects
divided into seven
categories and four
instances per category.
And I acquired it for
four different days
in order to test also
incremental learning
capabilities.
The dataset is available
on the IIT website.
And you can also
use it, for example,
for the project of trust
five if you are interested.
And this is an example
of the kind of videos
that I acquired considering
one of the 28 objects.
There are four videos for
the train, four for the test,
acquired in four
different conditions.
The object is undergoing random
transformations, mainly limited
to 3D rotations.
And as you can see, the
difference between the days
is mainly limited to the
fact that we are just
changing the conditions
in the environment--
for example, the background
or the lighting conditions.
And we acquired eight videos
for each of the 28 objects
that I show you.
So first of all, we
tried to find a measure,
as I was saying
before, to quantify
the confidence with
which we can expect
that the results and the
performance that we observe
on these benchmarks
will also hold
in the real usage of the system.
And to do this, first
of all, we focused only
on object identification
for the moment.
So the task is to discriminate
the specific instances
of objects among the pool of 28.
And we decided to estimate for
an increasing number of objects
to be discriminated from 2 to
28 the empirical probability
distribution of the
identification accuracy
that we can observe
statistically
for a fixed number of objects.
That is depicted here in
the form of box plots.
And also, we estimated for
each fixed number of objects
to be discriminated
the minimum accuracy
that we can expect to achieve
with increasing confidence
levels.
And this is a sort
of data sheet.
The idea is to provide an
idea to an hypothetical user
of the robot of the
identification accuracy
that can be expected given
a certain pool of objects
to be discriminated.
So the second point that
I'll briefly describe you
is the fact that we
investigated the effect
of having a more or less precise
segmentation in the image.
So we evaluated the task
of identifying the 28
objects with different
levels of segmentation
starting from the whole image
up to a very precise amount
of segmentation of the objects.
It can be seen
that, indeed, even
if in principle these
convolutional networks are
trained to classify
objects in the world image
as it is in the
ImageNet dataset,
it is still true
that in our case
we observed that there is still
a large benefit from having
a fine-grained segmentation.
So probably the network is
not able to completely discard
the new relevant information
that is in the background.
So this is a possible
interesting direction
of research.
And finally, the last point
that I decided to tell you--
I will skip on the
incremental part,
because it's an ongoing work
that I'm doing with Raffaello--
is about the exploitation
of the temporal contextual
information.
Here, you can see
the same kind of plot
that I showed you before.
So the task is object
identification,
increasing number of objects.
And the dot black line
represent the accuracy
that you obtain if
you consider, as you
were asking before, the
classification of each
frame independently.
So you can see that in this
case the accuracy that you get
is pretty low, considering
that we have to discriminate
between only 28 objects.
However, it is also
true that as soon
as you start considering instead
of the prediction given looking
only at the current frame,
the most frequent prediction
occurred in a temporal
window, so in the previous,
let's say, 50 frames.
You can boost your
condition accuracy a lot.
As you can see here,
from green to red,
increasing the length
of the temporal window
increases the recognition
accuracy that you get.
This is a very simple approach.
But it is showing that actually
it is relevant in the fact
that you are actually dealing
with videos instead of images
in the wild.
And it is another
direction of research.
So finally, in the
last part of my talk,
I would like to tell
you about the work
that I'm actually doing
now, which is concerning
about most object
categorization tasks instead
of identification.
And this is the
reason why we decided
to acquire a new
dataset, which is
larger than the previous ones.
Because it is composed not
only by more categories, but,
in particular, by more
instances per category
in order to be able to perform
categorization experiments as I
told you.
Here, you can see the categories
with which we are starting
are 28 divided into seven
macro categories, let's say.
But the idea of this dataset
is to have a continuously
expandable in time dataset.
So there is an
application that we
used to acquire these datasets.
And the idea is to perform
periodical acquisitions
in order to incrementally enrich
the knowledge of the robot
about the objects in the scene.
Also, another important
factor regarding this dataset
is that differently
from the previous one
this would be divided and
tagged by nuisance factors.
And in particular,
for each object,
we are acquiring
different videos
where we isolate the
different transformations
that the object is undergoing.
So we have a video
where the object is just
at different scales.
Then it is rotating
on the plane.
Outside the plane,
it is translating.
And then there is
a final video where
all of this transformation
occurs simultaneously.
And finally, to
acquire this dataset we
decided to use the depth
information, so that in the end
we acquired both the left
and the right to cameras.
And in principle,
this information
could be used to obtain the
3D structure of the objects.
And this is the idea
that we used in order
to make the robot focusing
on the object of interest
using disparity.
Disparity is very
useful in this case,
because it allows to detect
unknown objects just given
the fact that we know that
we want the robot focused
on the closest
objects in the scene.
So it is a very
powerful method in order
to have the robot
tracking a known
object with all different
lighting conditions and so on.
Yeah.
And here, you can see
this is the left camera.
This is the disparity map.
This is its segmentation, which
provides an approximate region
of interest around the object.
And this is the final output.
So I started
acquiring the first--
well, it should be red, but
it's not very clear I mean.
I started acquiring
the first categories
among these 21
listed here, which
are the squeezer, sprayer,
the cream, the oven
glove, and the bottle.
For each row, you see the tiny
instances that I collected.
And the idea is to
continue acquiring them
when I come back in Genoa.
And so here, you can see an
example of the five videos.
Actually, I acquired
10 videos per object,
five for the training set
and five for the test set.
And you can see that
in the different videos
the object is undergoing
different transformations.
And this is the final one while
these transformation are mixed.
Oh, the images here
are not segmented yet.
So you can see the whole image.
But in end, also the information
about the segmentation
and disparity and so
on will be available.
And this dataset
regarding the 50 object
that I acquired together
with the application
that I'm using to
acquire the dataset
are available if you
are willing to use them
for the projects in trust
five, for example, in order
to investigate the
invariant properties
of the different
representations.
And so that's it.